I mean this Reverend Christian Reverend
brought it up this is another thing that
they attacked Muslims on having caring
for multiple families yes yes yes penny
yeah yeah or as I call extending the
family right so what happens is there's
a Christian pastor you can find this he
wrote a book because he's in one part of
the world where they have such an axis
of women
yeah and even the president he's giving
incentives for men he's begging men okay
we have access of women by the year 2020
we are gonna have women in Ghana between
the ages of 15 and 55 three million from
the statistics of 2010 police announced
the census 2010 will check between the
ages of 15 and 55 we are going to have 3
million women who will not find husbands
if each man marijuana wife Tanzania has
30 million women 20 million men in
February of this year President John
McHugh fully was begging literally
begging the men to take two three wives
because they're over technically a woman
come for husbands and you know what that
means no ok yogi increasing prostitution
as from marital Affairs
they'll be increasing unwanted
pregnancies then abortions sexually
transmitted diseases and when there's
access woman he said the big ones are
yet to be born
right you see the big ones the old
marriages will collapse because the men
will leave them and quintic new eyes so
why do you say that polygamy is
destabilized destabilizing think about
monogamy as well I think your point is
made thank you very much Reverend Daniel
Ellison has made a very strong point
these are Christians these are
Christians now espousing and calling for
this because it goes back to many much
of the natural way yeah there have been
in history there's like Anabaptist
Christians in German community can one
can one of you you know how our friend
my friend Joe Rogan yes I think he's the
guy you know Joe when you're looking for
the guy for the statistic or somebody's
name oh yeah but I looks it up can you
look up I'm curious to know president
calls for the president calls for
polygyny and his country
yes yeah
can you look light up and it's look just
it's a solution now I'm saying find
something better it's not something
that's obligatory but it's a it's a
solution to a growing problem and
they're having it the president I mean
this guy I mean he's what is it that's
another one see this is not even the one
that I'm yeah yes that's the thing we
have you have a small community in the
world has their worldview and now you're
trying to do they're doing doua for the
rest of us yes is that no you absolutely
right in fact most world religions
openly endorse these things obviously
it's these churches or and/or the
religious communities of those revisions
but sometimes to press those things for
legalistic reasons but certainly they're
already Jewish community they believe in
they believe in polygamy a large portion
of those things if you look at their
rulings a lot of their clerics even to
this day as well they're talking about
political polygamy religion is something
which is very much practice which is men
marrying more than one woman and the
Anabaptist I remember even after the
whole Martin Luther experience in the
16th 17th centuries and the Protestant
Reformation that emerged a group called
the Anabaptist Christians and they I
think they made actually obligatory
obligatory from man to have at least two
wives and they used biblical verses to
to justify their their belief and so on
I mean obviously most of the world
religions have this but the point is
this once again we go back to her
premise I promise is that different
things are treated in different ways and
if we're saying that the the physical
physiological and emotional
infrastructure of a man is
differentiated almost in its entirety
from that of a woman then certainly it's
prescriptions regarding marriage and
divorce should be slightly different in
that regard otherwise there will be a
universality where it's inappropriate
for it to be so obviously a man having
more than one wife comes with a lot of
responsibilities yes and it comes with a
lot of restriction as well from Islamic
chronic perspective and can only be done
and you know in certain conditions
I mean if saying you know obviously
precautions are taken and agreements are
made yeah and so on
but it's it is a solution and it is a
solution which has helped humanity he a
four-time historically and continues to
do so yes and in fact there's a growing
problem in many societies well we travel
go to Africa we go to Asia we go to
these places and we find that there's a
there's a problem with like the four
sisters that people for some reason from
some strange reason they become outcasts
and in their community even though
really and truly from a practical
experience perspective they have more
experience if you think about it right
yeah they've been through something and
they they have more experience and say a
person has not been married before
yeah yeah that's the one yes John
McCauley social issues fully well yes
he's not forcing you but he's
encouraging so the thing is it's a
natural thing if you look at
sociological trends it makes a lot of
sense for a man sometimes tonight we
have to revive this sooner so maybe
maybe in another country not now you go
III only brought that up is to for the
empowering aspect of because you we
brought up connecting it back to the
natural way I mean of course the number
one natural way I mean the number one
thing is that pure monotheism that's
that thing that every human being I mean
it's a part of that nature that connect
to worship the Creator not the creation
it's just part of the human nature but
these other things that Muslims feel
deep power they feel like you know when
you talk about so many of these things
they feel like how can my religion
everybody's against it but then when you
bring up a lot of these issues this is
this is amazing like it's just it brings
people back to like wow I didn't know
this for instance like people get teased
about alcohol for instance you know and
then recent study for instance concludes
that no amount of alcohol is good for
the human being but the previous study
we all heard that because it was now a
gimmick what they had is faulty they had
the alcohol companies funding they were
funding I'm sorry
yeah the alcohol companies were funding
these studies that promoted alcohol yes
a new study comes out so the last is
Lancet no amount of alcohol is good and
actually who reports that one in one
person every 10 seconds dies from
alcohol consumption so now that Muslims
at the party right somewhere maybe he's
not supposed to be or even he's in the
place where work party and now he's you
know being offered this alcohol and
everybody's saying come on a glass of
wine a day it's no good how can you
really didn't deny something that's you
know good for your health you follow me
or for instance we talked about fasting
right people make fun of you like how
can you starve you so what's going on
but now we're quoting the scientific
facts they're all coming to the
forefront right
anything in the Deen is the natural way
there's nothing that the creator told us
to do even though they're making fun of
us one day now the joke's on you die how
can you fast all day now you're seeing
man this is for longevity for life you
know all of these kings things coming to
the forefront now but we're not doing it
for the for the hell for this because
the science is coming out we're doing it
because we trust in our Creator but now
we get to reap both absolutely and you
know the quran says a lie allen woman
Holika a whole lot fo beer does he not
know what he creates it and he is lost
you know the most all aware he is
all-knowing he so why waste all of our
time you know trying to find
sociological and psychological solutions
when all of it has been sent to us
through the final messenger mohammed
salah rios allah which all his approach
all his actions been approved stamp of
approval from the crater all-knowing i
mean that's just the major so these i
just bring up we brought this point this
point because this this is empowering i
mean it's just you know this is just
more and more evidence in evidence upon
the quran that we have you know with the
most evidence that this is indeed from
the creator and muhammad peace and
busters be upon him was like jesus moses
abraham all the other message he was a
messenger sent as a mercy to mankind
calling us out of the love to submit our
will to the crater and get to jena
paradise yeah well Eddie thank you
there's a lot of gem so you're talking
about gems
you know golf is the law of gold now
they can read from this from this
podcast especially when you're talking
about health etc so I think it's very
important for Muslims you know to have
that awareness to have that as you put
it quite succinctly nutrition will take
them